cet événement ce week-end le Grand Prix
Explorer qui a cartonné allez-y lâchez
vous lâchez-vous 22 streamers et
youtubeurs ce soir assemblés au circuit
Bugatti du Mans pour participer à une
course de formule 4 diffuseur live sur
twitch
l'événement organisé par le youtubeur
Squeezie a réuni 40 000 spectateurs et
plus d'un million de viewers sur twitch
un record français et la cinquième plus
grosse audience mondiale Squeezie
qu'est-ce qu'on est partout le public
Bugatti et c'est le youtubeur Sylvain
qui a remporté la course sous des
commentaires sponsorisés par misopaïne
[Applaudissements]
ça fait beaucoup plus d'audience que
Philippe Vendel sur Europe 1
le dernier record c'est inoxtag avec
700000 et après il faut voir que aussi
il rapporte de l'argent pour des
associations en fait ça a été initié
parce qu'il avait dit si on atteint
80000 pour l'association pour
l'événement caritatif pour les alors moi
j'ai j'ai félicité Squeezie et c'est
vrai que ça m'a mes équipes m'ont dit
mais tu es fou on aurait pas dû le
féliciter parce qu'il t'avait mis un TAC
il y a quelques années
[Applaudissements]
bien et il paraît qu'il m'a mis un TAC
dans l'émission alors c'était en 2017
salut ou celle que vous aimeriez ne plus
voir en 2017 je n'attends pas 2017 pour
ne plus voir les gens que je veux plus
voir quand même quand même deux
personnes qu'on a plus envie de voir
écoute on m'a dit de pas la faire Cyril
Hanouna
2017 allez c'est parti le clash
[Applaudissements]
alors
non non c'est pas du tout une vanne
c'est pas du tout une vanne ah non non
non non
c'est parti
donc c'est un coup bas parce que on lui
a dit il a dit déjà préparé la question
exactement
bravo machines
[Applaudissements]
après c'est vrai qu'à l'époque en 2017
je mettais une tarte pour ça maintenant
je me sens bien sûr
là il y a une tarte qui parle mais c'est
bien qu'il le sache quand même non en
ça aurait pu en 2007 tu étais un gamin à
l'époque c'était un gamin maintenant
[Applaudissements]
allez on verra bien